hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today I want to talk to you
about the life cycle of a pretty
terrible parasite called hookworm now
hookworm is a parasite specifically the
kind of helmets with neither worm which
we can tell from its name so close the
parasite didn't set up words of 800
million people per year globally so
certainly a serious parasite for many
for many people's experiences the worm
is particularly noteworthy because it
actually penetrates right through
unbroken skin of the host so a lot of
times various pathogens will actually
Nene but a cut in the skin to be able to
enter through the skin hookworm doesn't
need that it can actually burn right
through healthy unbroken skin and
ultimately it lived in the small
intestine where it attaches to the
intestinal walls sometimes for years and
sucks the hosts blood now this leads to
some pretty uh some pretty severe side
effects resulting from anemia that is
that the blood is shot blood is where a
lot of our body's iron is stored and so
hosts get anemia which is an iron
deficiency and the media then goes on to
cause its own problems including delayed
growth and delayed mental development or
order mental impairment now we said
perform as a parasite parasite is
actually a form of
meiosis which is where two organisms
live and really close contact with each
other in particular parasitism is what
we call a plus/minus form that means
that of the two organisms involved in
that symbiotic event so the two
organisms here being the hookworm and
its host one of those organisms benefit
from the symbiosis the Bennis that the
finnex that are here would be the
hookworm and then the other organism is
harmed and of course time the case of
all events of parasitism the one being
harmed is the host if you are interested
in symbiosis and about learning more
about parasitism and other forms of
symbiosis including mutualism and
commensalism please see my video on the
different types of symbiosis but to
continue here let's not talk about the
lifecycle of hookworm now a hookworm
infection begins with and with an egg
now egg perform eggs are shed in human
feces so an infected host hyper forms
inside them their feces will contain
huge huge numbers of hookworm egg and
this is actually the diagnostic stage
meaning that you can take a fecal sample
from a person and actually see under a
microscope all of the different eggs in
the feces is there that's how a hookworm
infection is typically diagnosed now
these eggs these eggs if they make it
into soil they can actually have in the
warm soil into the next developmental
stage which is marking and they need
warm soil to do this and this is why
cook learn is typical
a part of the tropical disease because
it says probable temperature that allow
the favorable conditions necessary for
the eggs to hatch into larvae now this
early larval form has a particular name
it's called the arrested of form stage
of the larkey now over the course of a
couple of weeks the resident forms
larvae will mature into a more mature
form the larval stage here hopefully
reform and these larvae can actually
survive approximately three to four
weeks in the soil and that is when
conditions are particularly favorable so
I live in temperature and moisture
conditions are right now it is these
four layer form larvae that can actually
burrow through the host skin so here we
have a picture a drawing of a human foot
and the lardy can actually burrow right
through the skin now the larvae are
going to be able to burrow through
whatever skin is most in contact with
the soil which of course is where
they're living and so typically this is
is done when a human goes barefoot and
have their their barefoot and contact
with the soil now once this body enters
the human body it goes through a really
search Hewitt s route first it enters
the bloodstream from the bloodstream it
moves to the heart from the heart it can
travel through the through the body to
the lung and then it can and then the
larvae actually gets cost up so get
cock-up from the lung up to the pharynx
and then it gets swallowed I go to the
stomach and the lardy that survives the
stomach acid conditions make it to the
small intestines and it is here in the
small intestine where the lardy mature
into adults
so the lardy mature into adult worms
the adult worms are the ones that then
attach to the lining of the small
intestine and suck blood they can stay
there for two years and during the time
that they are alive within the body
they're constantly laying eggs
huge huge numbers of eggs but then get
excreted from the human body in the
feces and in the cycle and continue now
luckily hookworm has been all that
eradicated in most developed nation and
this is for a few different reasons
first we have anti holistic drugs so
these are drugs that highte worm
infections we can also take iron pills
to counteract the anemia that comes from
the blood loss and then we can also
break this this chain of transmission by
doing for two main things encouraging
people to wear shoes and making sure
that everybody has shoes this is of
course a bigger problem in various
developing nations and also we can we
can break this chain of transmission in
another place as well and that's right
here making sure that the human feces
that contains the eggs does not actually
get into soil and of course this can be
done when countries have proper
sanitation and public health
infrastructure and that's why we don't
really hear about a forum in the United
States anymore but certainly it is a
bigger problem in many other parts of
the world and you can see that from the
number who are infected now if you are
interested in learning about other types
of parasite life cycles please see my
other video which is on the life cycle
of the parasite that causes the
the disease schistosomiasis and that's
another kind of worm parasite so check
that one out if you're interested thanks
for watching biology professor